j'aurais commencé par remercier le
président ce qui pour son message
passionné de leur jeu les écouter dans
ma résidence
c'était un message fort convaincant
porte à faux
il s'exprime au nom d'un peuple qui a
fait preuve d'une force remarquable face
à une agression brutale à courage
qui caractérise non seulement les
ukrainiens mais aussi le monde entier
poutine inflige une destruction sans
précédent
l'ukraine des établissements résidentiel
des hôpitaux
j'en parlais justement avec
avec le commandant qui se tient derrière
moi c'est incroyable je suis fière des
rapports ont indiqué que les forces
russes ont pris en otage des centaines
de médecins et d'infirmiers à mario paul
c'est un scandale à la face du monde
le monde et une liste dans son soutien à
l'ukraine et nous sommes déterminés à
faire payer à poutine un prix important
nous nous sommes entendus avec nos
partenaires nos alliés pour fournir une
aide importante et nous allons continuer
à travailler dans les jours il ya dans
les semaines à venir nous allons
infliger des dommages importants à
l'économie russe
nous allons collaborer avec nos alliés
de l'otan avec beaucoup d'autres pays ce
qui est en jeu ici c'est les principes
des états unis et des nations unies
il s'agit de liberté il s'agit du droit
des peuples à disposer d'eux mêmes il
s'agit de veiller à ce que
les ukrainiens ne soit jamais victimes
des russes quelles que soient ses
avancées sur le terrain nous avons
entendu les appels à l'aide pour
davantage d'équipements et d'outils pour
lutter contre l' agression russe et
c'est ce que nous faisons nous avions
déjà commencé à et et l'ukraine avant
que sept recommence au travers
d'exercices à la frontière en mars de
l'année dernière
nous avons pris les initiatives de
poutine très au sérieux nous avons
renforcé la sécurité
la sécurité de l'ue créé à la hauteur de
650 millions de dollars par des
équipements
à utiliser sur terre
nous avons fourni des équipements à même
de freiner l'avancé une chrétienne nous
avons également consacré 350 millions de
dollars supplémentaires
des milliers d'équipements titre anti
chars des hélicoptères de transport des
des navires des systèmes de radar pour
suivre les déplacements des drones des
équipements tactique des dispositifs
d'imagerie satellitaire
et cela a clairement aidé les ukrainiens
a affiché des pertes importantes aux
forces russes qu
samedi mon administration a autorisé le
déploiement 200 millions de dollars
supplémentaires et à nouveau je ne sers
de mon autorité présidentielle pour
activer une assistance sécuritaire
supplémentaire pour permettre aux
ukrainiens de se défendre à hauteur de
800 millions de dollars supplémentaires
il s'agit de fournir de nouveaux
systèmes de défense aux ukrainiens à
hauteur d'un milliard de dollars pour
sept semaines seulement nous avons
collaboré avec l'armée ukrainienne pour
repousser l'invasion et je remercie le
congrès pour son appui cette nouvelle
aide va apporter une aide sans précédent
à l'ukraine vie son
système entier rien pour veiller à ce
que les ukrainiens puisse continuer à
faire front face aux attaques venues des
airs et pour pouvoir protéger l'espace
aérien ukrainien nous avons répondu au
président chavez fiche pour permettre à
l'ukraine
daguerre des systèmes de longue portée
une nouvelle aide qui inclut également
9000 système anti char il s'agit de
dispositifs portatifs
hautement et d'autres précisions qui
permettent de détruire de façon efficace
les équipements plage et
cela inclut également 7000 armements
légers qui permettent aux ukrainiens aux
hommes et aux femmes qui défendent leur
ville en tant que civil de se défendre
nous avons également prévu la fourniture
ou de mortier de munitions vingt mille
20 millions de cartouches
et cela est la preuve de notre
engagement à soutenir la défense
mais nous ne faisons pas seul nous
allier nos partenaires sont intervenus
pour renforcer cette assistance
sécuritaire nous allons continuer à
faciliter cette assistance les états
unis et ses parcs et leurs partenaires
s'engagent envers la sécurité de
et ce n'est que le début
mais j'aimerais être franc avec vous
cela peut durer longtemps
nous devons poursuivre notre soutien et
que l'ukrainien face à l'agression
immoral de poutine il inflige aux 6 à
ces populations civiles nous
continuerons de les soutenir à l'heure
où ils se battent pour la démocratie
pour leur liberté
nous fournirons à l'ukraine les armes
dont elle a besoin pour se défendre nous
continuerons à mobiliser l'aide
humanitaire pour permettre à ceux qui se
trouvent toujours en ukraine et ceux qui
fuient l'ukraine de rester en vie nous
avons coordonner nos efforts avec les
états voisins des milliers de tonnes de
nourriture d'eau de médicaments et de
fournitures de base ont été fournies aux
populations nos experts sur le terrain
se trouve également en moldavie dans
d'autres pays voisins pour procéder à
des évaluations afin de pouvoir
acheminer l'aide humanitaire de façon
urgente là où les gens en ont besoin
nous souhaitons également l'économie
craignant grâce à une aide financière
directe avec nos partenaires nous allons
maintenir la pression sur l'économie
russe
nous allons maintenir ses efforts sur la
scène internationale voilà notre
objectif faire payer à poutine le prix
qui doit payer et nous permettre aux
ukrainiens de faire des avancées à la
table des négociations
nous ferons tout notre possible pour
pouvoir mettre un terme à cette guerre
tragique et absurde
nous soutiendrons toujours là le désir
des hommes à être libre
que les choses soient claires les etats
unis se tiennent aux côtés de ceux qui
désirent la liberté et ce sera toujours
le cas
je vais à présent signé ce texte pour
pouvoir matérialiser cette aide que dieu
protège le peuple ukrainien
je vais donc signé ce document
[Musique]